c'est une vie plus heureuse écrit un
autre
sébastien car tellement content de vous
rencontrer parce que vous incarnez
samuel chappedelaine dans la nouvelle
adaptation cinématographique de maeyer
shadowland c'est un grand lecteur
amoureux de la culture québécoise je
m'ajuste c'était quelque chose un rêve
d'une quelconque façon oui c'est vrai
c'est d'ailleurs l'oeuvre de louis hémon
mariage à des livres que j'ai lus quand
j'étais jeune adolescent que j'ai eus
jeunes adultes puis que j'ai relu pour
les besoins du film puis c'est un très
très grand livre je considère christophe
c'est un grand livre de la culture
québécoise écrit par un français mais
qui parle de nous de manière
extraordinairement profonde et
pénétrante il ya aussi quelque chose
encore une fois je parlais d'identité
est quelque chose qui parle de
l'identité des québécois aussi une
difficulté
à s'enraciner à se satisfaire de ce qui
est là pour des raisons sur lesquelles
on pourrait épiloguer longtemps mais je
trouve que c'est une des figures de
l'identité du roman qui moi me plaît
beaucoup samuel les et entre
l'enracinement terriens puis le bois
qu'il l'appelle comme dit sa femme laura
le brouhaha des sorcellerie pour vous
les hommes je t'aime
et c'est comprend que je t'ai tout dans
le film life stories histoires d'un coup
vous incarnez un point dépendants
affectifs qui est soumis à la dictature
du jem sur les réseaux sociaux comment
vous gérez saint chamand la dictature du
jeu mais en tant qu'acteur la dictature
du jem pour les comédiens c'est un
phénomène qui est assez récent mauger
peuvent vraiment donné là dedans je
pensais pas pouvoir aujourd'hui je suis
déjà suffisamment exposé j'ai
l'impression que c'est important pour
moi de garder une certaine distance
avec le public plus qu'avec ma vie ma
vie privée et la vie de l'acteur est une
chose puis surtout ce que c'est
important de garder un certain mystère
encore une fois une certaine
privautés sur sa vie pour garder le
spectateur les spectatrices comme libre
face à ce que je vais faire de pas voir
en arrière plan qui polluent
l'interprétation qui polluent
sortes de choses qui sont
superfétatoire qui ont pas vraiment
reliés pire rapport avec ce qu'on est en
train de présenter c'est vraiment la
raison la plus importante je trouve que
je dirais
doivent incarner dédé fortin dans dédé à
travers les brumes est-ce que douze ans
plus tard c'est encore un personnage qui
dit penser aux résidences j'y pense
souvent jeu sa musique joue souvent dans
plein d'endroits ce musée que le legs
des colloques et
considérable jeudi c'est fou aussi
comment la transmission s'est faite aux
jeunes générations
ça m'arrive de voir des très jeunes gens
qui viennent me voir parce qu'on veut
fink qui peut-être grâce au film parce
que leurs parents leur en ont parlé
montre que c'est un groupe et c'est une
musique qui fait partie intégrante de la
culture québécoise aujourd'hui et donc
du coup oui c'est sûr qu'on aurait forcé
le personnage mais cette légende on en
fait aussi fait partie de ma vie de la
voir jouer c'est quelque chose qui m'a
énormément donné et puis oui c'est
quelqu'un que je porte dans mon coeur
puis c'est un travail aussi que qui vaut
toujours me restait comme un moment
charnière dans ma vie
moi je suis la génération de colocation
c'est jacques locas que le début
ça fait dix ans que par registre d'alban
avec le groupe chrysler
non mais je dirais que mon dieu c'est
certainement pas moi de me prononcer là
dessus aujourd'hui donc le groupe est
vraiment sur la glace la glace sèche
pour ce tir de même sèche depuis un bon
moment
puis c'est pas la pandémie qui en est la
cause
je sais pas si on a commencé le bal
quand on avait au début de la vingtaine
on eu des enfants mais ce n'est pas la
seule raison il ya aussi fait que comme
artiste je pense que c'était pour moi
c'était important de
essayé d'exprimer des choses
de manière différente de d'essayer
d'essayer d'autres médiums aussi je sais
pas pour la suite qui va se produire
mais est-ce que vous venu m'annoncer la
mort de nos contenus j'ai pas
on se trouve à la place des arts vous
allez revenir la semaine prochaine pour
rêver folie vous incarnez un poète
cocaïnomane qui a mal terminé sa vie on
peut dire comme sa collaboration avec
brigitte en 15 c'est quand je pense à
votre neuvième production avec elle on
dira que c'est votre âme soeur c'est
fusionnel votre relation c'est vrai
c'est vrai c'est une arme ça je pense
que c'est le bon terme pour définir la
relation vont ensemble c'est vraiment
une rencontre importante dans ma vie
grande amie mais aussi une grande
artiste qui notre permis de faire des
choses que je pense pas que j'aurais pu
faire sans l'avoir rencontré donc ça
prend absolument je pense que pour les
comédiens c'est formidable d'avoir un
lien aussi fort avec un metteur en scène
où le metteur en scène donc mots et
brigitte a eu et les diablement un
impact considérable dans ma vie donc je
ne saurai jamais assez la remercier pour
ça
sébastien l'écart s'est visiblement
votre année je remercie beaucoup merci
merci à vous